a serving member of the Armed Forces has
been charged by counter-terrorism police
with offenses under the official Secrets
act I shazid is at Westminster
magistrates court for us now when what
more can you tell us Aisha
well Thomas Newsome appeared here at
Westminster magistrates Court earlier
today the 36 year old was dressed in
Gray as he spoke to the judge to confirm
his name and his date of birth of course
as you mentioned he's a serving member
of the Armed Forces and he's facing
several charges charged with fences
contrary to section two and eight of the
official Secrets act he's the charges
were made following an investigation by
the Metropolitan Police as counter
terrorism command unit now the crown
prosecution service alleged that on the
17th of April Thomas Newsom without
lawful Authority made a damaging
disclosure of information relating to
defense which was in his position by
virtue of was it in his possession by
virtue of his position and then on April
the 18th the CPS alleges he had in his
possession or under his control again by
virtue of his position as such documents
which he failed to take such care of as
to prevent the unauthorized disclosure
of these documents as a person in his
position May reasonably be be expected
to take so those are the charges for now
he's been remanded in custody and he
will be appearing here again at
Westminster magistrates court next week
on Friday the 28th of April
Aisha for now thank you